>> Laura: IN THE IMMEDIATE
AFTERMATH OF THOSE MASS
SHOOTINGS INTO MOSQUE IN
NEW ZEALAND, THE MEDIA WORKED
OVERTIME TO TRY TO LINK
PRESIDENT TRUMP TO THE TRAGEDY,O
PRESIDENT TRUMP TO THE TRAGEDY,R
PRESIDENT TRUMP TO THE TRAGEDY,E
PRESIDENT TRUMP TO THE TRAGEDY,.
THIS SECOND NARRATIVE CONTINUED
TODAY WITH NEW ERRONEOUS CHARGE
CHARGES.
>> YES, HE'S CRAZY.
HE'S A WHITE NATIONALIST.
>> A PERSONAL GRIEVANCE THAT IS
PRECISELY CONSISTENT WITH THE
WHITE NATIONALIST AGENDA.
>> THIS WHOLE RACIAL BIGOTED
PERCEPTION OF THE PRESIDENT IS
AN ALBATROSS AROUND HIS NECK.
STEEL AND JOINING ME NOW
EXCLUSIVELY, I'M SO HAPPY HE'S
WITH US.
I'VE BEEN ASKING HIM TO COME ON
HIS BEN CARSON.
THE SECRETARY OF HOUSING AND
URBAN DEVELOPMENT.
DR. CARSON, AS THE ONLY
AFRICAN-AMERICAN IN THE
CARBONATE DOWN THE CABINET, YOU
CAN TAKE A SWING AT THAT.
I HEARD WHITE NATIONALIST FOR
HIS POLICIES, HIS EMPHASIS IS ON
WHITE NATIONALISM OVER AND OVER
AGAIN.
YOUR REACTION?
>> THERE IS A NARRATIVE BEEN
PAINTED THERE, I HAD THE
OPPORTUNITY TO INTERACT WITH
RACIST PEOPLE THROUGHOUT MY
LIFE.
AND HE IS NOT ONE.
HE IS SO EASY TO BE AROUND.
SO RELAX.
TREATS YOU WITH THE UTMOST
RESPECT.
I TALK WITH HIM EARLY ON
ABOUT THE PLIGHT OF MANY PEOPLE
PARTICULARLY IN THE INNER-CITY,
AND THE COMPASSION HE SHOWS IS
VERY IMPRESSIVE.
HE DOESN'T WEAR IT ON HIS
SLEEVE.
HE BELIEVES THAT A RISING TIDE
LIFTS ALL BOATS.
HE DOESN'T GO AROUND PLAYING
IDENTITY POLITICS.
HE THINGS, LET'S FIX THIS SO
EVERYBODY DOES WELL.
>> Laura: ONE OF THE THINGS I
FOUND THE MOST AMAZING THAT GOT
ALMOST NO COVERAGE BECAUSE HE'S
GOTTEN HAMMERED RECENTLY --
WE'LL GET TO THAT.
BUT YOU ACTUALLY WORKED WITH
BILL de BLASIO.
YOU CAN'T GET MORE OF A LIBERAL
MAYOR THEN BILL de BLASIO.
YOU WORK WITH HIM BECAUSE IN
YORK HOUSING AUTHORITY HAS BEEN
PLAGUED WITH ALL SORTS OF
PROBLEMS.
DILAPIDATED HOUSING -- THIS GOES
ON AND ON.
THERE WAS A FEDERAL TAKEOVER OF
NEW YORK CITY HOUSING AUTHORITY
JANUARY 31ST, IT IT BECAME
OFFICIAL.
I WOULD'VE THOUGHT THAT
DE BLASIO WOULD'VE HAMMERED
YOU.
de BLASIO WENT ON AND ON ABOUT
HOW IT'S A NEW PATH FORWARD.
HE SAID YOU ARE VERY RESPONSIVE,
VERY RESPONSIVE.
WHAT WE'VE DONE TODAY CREATES A
STRONG PATH FORWARD, HE SAID, A
TANGIBLE PATH FORWARD BECAUSE IT
WILL CHANGE AND IMPROVE THE
LIVES OF PUBLIC HOUSING
RESIDENTS WHO WANTED TO MAKE
SURE THERE WOULD BE RESULTS.
WHAT HAPPENED THERE?
YOU AND HE ARE PALS NOW?
>> I WILL TELL YOU WHAT REALLY
HAPPENED AND I WISH THIS WOULD
HAPPEN IN OUR CONGRESS.
WE JUST DECIDED TO PUT THE
PEOPLE FIRST.
WE SAID, WHATEVER WE TALK ABOUT,
LET'S ALWAYS KEEP THE PEOPLE AT
THE FOREFRONT AND DO THOSE
THINGS THAT WILL ACTUALLY
BENEFIT THEM.
THAT'S THE APPROACH WE'VE TAKEN
IN ALL OF OUR PROJECTS.
YOU KNOW, WE ARE LOOKING AT OUR
REACT SCORING, LOOKING AT WAYS
TO GET PEOPLE OUT OF THE
SQUALOR.
A LOT OF PEOPLE SAYING WHY DO
YOU LET PEOPLE LIVE IN THIS
DILAPIDATED PLACE?
IT'S BECAUSE WE DON'T HAVE
ANOTHER PLACE TO PUT THEM.
SINCE WE'VE HAD ANOTHER
IF WE HAD ANOTHER PLACE TO PUT
THEM, BELIEVE ME, WE DO THAT.
YOU HAVE TO WEIGH A LOT OF THESE
THINGS CAREFULLY AND HAVING
GROWN UP AROUND THAT, I'M
INTERESTED IN MAKING SURE WE
GIVE PEOPLE THE TOP QUALITY THAT
WOULD ALLOW THEM TO GIVE THE
FREEDOM TO THINK ABOUT SOMETHING
OTHER THAN HOW THEY ARE GOING TO
SURVIVE THE NIGHT.
>> Laura: RENTS ARE GOING UP
IN CITIES ACROSS THE
UNITED STATES AND YET THE LEFT,
A LOT OF FAIR ISLE'S ACTIVISTS,
SAY THAT
10,000 UNITS OF PUBLIC HOUSING
ARE LOST TO DECAY ACCORDING TO
YOUR OWN DEPARTMENT AND SAYING
THAT YOU AREN'T DOING A LOT TO
FIX THIS.
>> THERE ARE A LOT WHO BELIEVE
THROWING MONEY AT THE PROBLEM IS
A SOLUTION.
FIRST OF ALL, THE BUDGET
PROPOSED MAKES SURE THAT WE
PROTECT EVERYBODY IN ALL THE
HOUSING PROGRAMS.
NOBODY IS GOING TO BE THROWN
OUT.
BUT WE ARE LOOKING AT THINGS
WHICH COMES AND REBUILDS AND A
LOT OF THESE DILAPIDATED PLACES
AND TAKES CARE OF THAT DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE THAT'S BEEN PUT OFF
FOR SO LONG BECAUSE THE SYSTEM
THAT WE HAVE BEEN USING ALLOWED
IT TO CONTINUE TO ACCUMULATE AND
PEOPLE TO GET FURTHER BEHIND.
WE ARE CHANGING TO A
PUBLIC-PRIVATE PARTNERSHIP
SYSTEM.
>> Laura: THAT'S WHAT THEY
DON'T LIKE.
IS THAT WHAT'S GOING ON?
I DIDN'T FOLLOW A LOT WHAT HUD
WAS DOING, BUT THEY ARE
ACTUALLY -- THERE ARE SOME
OPPORTUNITY ZONES, OBVIOUSLY
IT'S A HUGE, HUGE EFFORT THAT'S
CURRENTLY UNDERWAY.
THEY HAD MSNBC SAYING CURRENT
AND FORMER HUD PEOPLE SAYING YOU
DON'T HAVE A SENSE OF URGENCY
BECAUSE YOU ARE VERY CALM,
UNLIKE ME.
YOU ARE VERY CALM --
>> WOULD YOU LIKE TO HAVE A
NEUROSURGEON WHO PANICS EVERY
TIME HE DOES SURGERY?
NO, THEY ARE LOOKING AT THINGS
THE WAY THEY USED TO BE.
WE ARE LOOKING AT THINGS THE WAY
THEY NEED TO BE.
AND WE ARE CHANGING THINGS.
THEY CAN'T RELATE TO THAT.
AND -- YOU KNOW, I DON'T TALK
ABOUT THEM.
I DON'T BLAME THEM FOR THEY JUST
CAN'T UNDERSTAND.
THEY DON'T TALK TO US.
WHEN THEY DO TALK TO US, THEY
DISTORT WHAT'S GOING ON.
SO I DON'T REALLY WORRY ABOUT
THEM.
I JUST WORRY ABOUT DOING IS
WHAT'S RIGHT.
THE PROOF WILL BE IN THE
PUDDING.
WE ARE WORKING TO GET PEOPLE OUT
OF POVERTY, WITH THE OPPORTUNITY
ZONES, PEOPLE HAVE MADE A LOT OF
MONEY OVER THE LAST COUPLE OF
YEARS.
NOW WE ARE PROVIDING A MECHANISM
OR YOU CAN TAKE UNREALIZED
CAPITAL GAINS AND INVEST THEM IN
PLACES THAT HAVE TRADITIONALLY
BEEN NEGLECTED AND --
WE WOULD LIKE IN CHICAGO, AND A
LOT OF NEW FRIENDS THEY ARE IN
THE SHOW THAT WE DID IN INGLEWOO
THE SHOW THAT WE DID IN INGLEWO,
COMPTON, WE ARE GOING IN PARTS
OF DETROIT THAT ARE
TRADITIONALLY NOT CONSERVATIVE
PLACES.
BUT I THINK WE WOULD HOPE THAT
WE'LL SEE REAL PROGRESS.
>> OUR UNDERSTANDING IS PEOPLE
ARE OUR MOST VIABLE RESOURCE.
IF WE DEVELOP THEM AND MAKE THEM
PRODUCTIVE, WE ONLY STRENGTHEN
OURSELVES AS A NATION.
WE ONLY HAVE 300 MILLION PEOPLE.
INDIA AND CHINA HAVE SO MANY
PEOPLE.
WE WILL NEVER COMPETE WITH THEM
UNLESS WE LEARN TO DEVELOP OUR
PEOPLE AND I THINK WE UNDERSTAND
THAT.
>> Laura: APPARENTLY YOU JUST
PUT YOUR FEET UP ON YOUR DESK
ALL DAY AND SIPPING MY
MUAY THAIS,
EVERY WEEK IT'S THURSDAY
AFTERNOON.
>> THE WAY I LOOK AT IT, IF
THAT'S THE WORST THEY CAN SAY, I
GO HOME SOME WEEKENDS AND I MAY
LEAVE EARLY ON A FRIDAY IN ORDER
TO GET THERE?
IF THAT'S THE WORST THEY CAN
FIND, AS MUCH AS THEY'VE BEEN
SCRUTINIZING, WE ARE IN PRETTY
GOOD SHAPE.
>> Laura: THIS JOB COMPARED TO
NEUROSURGERY ON CHILDREN, WHAT
ARE YOU FINDING THE MOST AND
MOST FULFILLING?
>> OF COURSE, AS A SURGEON, I
STILL HAVE A SURGICAL
PERSONALITY.
>> Laura: GOT IT DONE NOW.
GET IT DONE.
>> HERE, YOU HAVE TO DEAL WITH
BUREAUCRACY.
BUREAUCRATS TEND TO THINK THE
RULES ARE MUCH MORE IMPORTANT
THAN THE GOALS.
ADJUSTING TO THAT.
BUT NOT ADJUSTING TO THE POINT
WHERE YOU CAN CAPITULATE TO
THAT.
TRYING TO CHANGE IT.
WE BROUGHT INTO HUD NOW A CFO.
WE DIDN'T HAVE A CFO FOR EIGHT
AND A HALF YEARS.
CAN YOU IMAGINE THE MONEY
POURING THROUGH THERE?
THERE WAS NOT THE PHYSICAL
CONTROL THAT YOU WOULD EXPECT.
NOW WE HAVE THAT.
WE ARE BRINGING IN THE KIND OF
CONTROLS THAT WILL ALLOW US TO
GIVE MORE FREEDOM TO THE VARIOUS
JURISDICTIONS BECAUSE WE CAN
KEEP TRACK OF WHERE THE MONEY IS
AND HOW IT'S BEING USED AND WHAT
THE TIMELINES ARE.
ALL OF THOSE THINGS ARE
CHANGING.
WE ARE UPGRADING OUR I.T.
SYSTEMS.
WE STILL HAVE A GOOD WAYS TO GO,
BUT WE ARE MAKING PROGRESS.
>> Laura: IS AT THE SLOW PACE
OF THINGS, OH, BEN CARSON TALKS
SO SLOWLY.
WE NEED MORE PEOPLE TALKING
SLOWLY TO MAKE SENSE IN MY VIEW.
BUT I WOULD IMAGINE THAT'S
FRUSTRATING FOR YOU.
THE PACE OF CHANGE.
I KNOW IT'S FRUSTRATING FOR THE
PRESIDENT AS WELL PRINT ARE YOU
GOING TO STICK AROUND FOR A
WHILE?
>> I AM PLANNING ON IT.
THERE WAS THIS HOOPLA A COUPLE
OF WEEKS ABOUT BEN CARSON
LEAVING.
I WAS ASKED WHAT I WAS GOING TO
DO.
I SET MY PREFERENCE IS TO GO
BACK IN THE PRIVATE SECTOR.
IT WAS EXTREMELY ENJOYABLE.
AND YOU HAD A GREAT DEAL OF
FREEDOM.
AND YOU HAD THAT I WAS SPEAKING
A LOT MORE AT THE TIME.
BUT WHAT WE ARE DOING IS ALSO
INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT.
>> Laura: DOES THAT MEAN
YOU'RE GOING TO STAY FOR THE
NEXT YEAR?
>> I WILL DEFINITELY FINISH OUT
THE FIRST TERM.
I'M OPEN TO A SECOND TERM.
>> Laura: SECRETARY CARSON, DO
NOT BE A STRANGER.